What can I get you the pbnb rhc on a roll
aren't you blessed with a fast metabolism
you're running a marathon or something
I'm in sort of a rush for the sandwich
a robbery gone wrong I need you here now Barry
I might give it every minute every second
every breath every muscle every step everywhere
now is that fast enough for you
can go anywhere another timeline Another Universe
so why do you want to stay in a fight to save this
one because this is the world where my mom lives
and fix things
you can also destroy everything this world
must die if you impact and change
the past you changed the future
want some help
you're, you are him, yeah
I'm Batman
we can fix this
nobody dies
I am
The Flash
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie there's a
brand new Flash trailer and a whole bunch of
Henry Cavill Superman scenes in it confirming
that he's in the movie for a lot of people that
were worried that they just wouldn't put him in
at all there's a bunch of other new footage so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos because the movie's so close to coming out
we'll also start the movie ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know what you want them to do just in general with
the flash character going forward after this just
starting at the beginning of the footage working
our way through shot by shot talking about Easter
eggs and WTF moments as we go along they have the
funny moment with him at the coffee shop getting
breakfast going to Central City Police Department
like he's on his way to work regularly like he
would be during a normal day and they just had
the joke about the shop clerk taking his time
making his order like PB and J okay great this
will just take a couple minutes to put together
but then Wally's getting it all these Justice
League problems erupt all over the world all at
the same time all different problems on the news
down in Guatemala he sees Henry cavill's Superman
working to stop a Volcan Kano from erupting and
destroying the area the other funny thing that's
going on here is that he's trying to decide who
to go help like oh he's got all these other
Justice League people like he's got Superman
Batman Wonder Woman Aquaman they all start having
their own problems who does he join in which part
of the world to help them when he's watching
Henry cavill's Superman stop the volcano from
exploding you also notice on the news ticker here
it says the White House pledges to help Guatemala
so the idea is that Henry Cavill is also working
with the U.S president at this time but I don't
think that we know who the actual U.S president
is within the world of the Justice League the
funny connection to this is that in the universe
of the boys TV show which is like a dark parody of
the DC and the Marvel comic book characters they
have a huge White House U.S government plot like
the whole idea is that Vaught is trying to get
into the White House take over the White House
basically then he gets the call from Alfred they
have that funny scene from the previous trailers
where he's trying to go help Batman because Batman
says I need you here in Gotham City that's where
all the scenes of him fighting these criminals
are happening and they continue in that moment
with the clerk taking his time making his PB and
J they make it seem like this huge epic event they
finish that and then he goes back to the coffee
shop in Central City and the guy is just finishing
his PB J order like oh was that fast enough for
you but it's only been a couple minutes one of
the other interesting things going on here too
is that when Ben Affleck's Batman is yelling at
him Barry I need you here now it sounds a lot
a lot like Kevin condroy's Batman voice a lot
of people asking about this because this is
from an earlier trailer no please don't stop
I am the night I am Batman I am this I am the
Knight I am Batman I don't think they're trying
to go for any kind of Kevin Conroy kind
of vibe or anything like that it's just
him doing a really cool version of the Batman
voice without any kind of special modulation
which makes you wish that they actually kind of
did this during the previous movies too Kevin
Conroy probably had one of the most iconic
Batman and Bruce Wayne voices of all time
that's why people say that his Batman is one
of the best Batmans of all time it's just that
he happened to be an animated Batman he did get
to play live action Batman briefly during crisis
on infinite Earth battle not with monsters lest
you become a monster in Batman Beyond I played
um an older Bruce Wayne he still had hope for
the world I can barely walk I don't wear that
again this Bruce Wayne he's become so broken
and so embittered by life that he sees no hope
for the world the point of this exoskeleton is to
support his body because he's been so beaten and
broken that he would not be able to stand up
without it and then they turn it on and I go
no I never thought I'd get a chance to do it on
camera because I was getting older and older and
older I was sort of Aging out of Batman you know
but luckily I aged into Old Bruce Wayne it'll be
interesting to see if there are any actual
references to his animated Batman because we
have the whole Multiverse of all I'm not expecting
it even though they're including all these Cameo
scenes from all different actors all over the
Canon bringing them together through the speed
force I don't think they're getting quite as
crazy as Spider-Man across the spider-verse
gets when you talk about blending live action
and animated elements together without getting
into spoilers for that movie I just posted like a
giant breakdown hour-long video for that you can
watch that and learn about everything that happens
during that movie it will be cool though if Barry
does see some animated versions of the characters
from across the Canon when he travels through the
speed force but just don't expect it in the movie
it looks like Batman has already given him the
flash ring with the brand new version of The Flash
suit I'm sure there'll be lots of opinions about
which version of The Flash shoot is the best one
look Zack Snyder's version of the suit which he
wore more recently in that Peacemaker post credit
scene with the Justice League in the brand new
version of The Flash suit which is also a little
bit different from the comics but I think the
idea is they were trying to make it a little more
comic bookie with the actual flash ring they also
have a funny moment here where you see the people
recognize him they call him the flashlight people
already calling him the flash which they weren't
doing during Justice League it that was the whole
joke of crisis on infinite Earth with the Grant
Gustin crossover that he was learning about the
flash name for the first time like the flash wow
that actually sounds like a cool name I think
I'm gonna start using that did the funny moment
where they asked for his autograph he asked for
their candy bar because he still needs some food
like it's more jokes about him being a snack hole
that he started during the Justice League movie
because the Flash TV show also ended its run one
of the last episodes they actually had a reference
to this because they did a joke about that during
the 90s John Wesley's ship Flash TV show you
want this one you know help yourself right thanks
would you uh would you like another one you see
him wolfing down a whole bunch of pizzas they
did a version that would Grant gustin's flash
but it was him going back to the night that his
mother was murdered so it was parents buying
him all the pizzas during The Flash movie he
just asked them for like the piece of the candy
bars that the woman hasn't finished eating yet
like are you done eating that are you sure I
really need those calories the way they got
around this problem in The Flash TV show in
the early Seasons I think it was like one of
the first couple of episodes that they did this
is that they had Cisco create this high calorie
candy bar and then they never referenced it
again like the flash just continued burning
all these calories and eating all these crazy high
calorie candy bars Ben Affleck also did say there
were supposed to be a bunch of Cameo scenes from
gal gadot's Wonder Woman during this big bridge
save it sounds like it was from the same event
the other funny thing is that he also says that
it's like the best Batman that he's ever done
in any movie ever so he's like maybe I should
come back now that's mostly tongue-in-cheek like
I do think that he's moved past the idea of doing
more superhero stuff but it's really more of a
never say ever kind of situation so as a fan I
would just say the best way to treat stuff like
this is Never Say Never but don't expect stuff
to happen like right away James Gunn did say that
they would cast a new version of Batman for all
their big Justice League crossovers as part of
the new DC 10-year plan that he developed they
did say when the Superman Legacy movie happens
in 2025 in that Universe there'll already be a
bunch of big characters that exist in the movie
they didn't say which character so I don't know
if the new version of Batman will also debut
in that or the new version of Damian Wayne
because that is the big deal if they're doing
a version of Damian Wayne Robin so obviously
Nightwing will be much older they're doing more
bat family so it'll be interesting to see which
other versions of Robin exist in the universe
when he starts changing all the timelines and
they have the big fight with Zod later in the
movie like the big final fight you see a bunch
more scenes of both versions of The Flash using
the speed force while fighting in a way that it
would have been really cool to see on The Flash TV
show like this is what the flash looks like when
he's using his powers while he's fighting one of
the other interesting things is that you see both
versions of the blast chasing each other through
the speed force trying to travel in time they
said there's sort of like a Back to the Future
element during it where he tries to go back in
time multiple times but things keep going badly
you also hear him arguing with the younger version
of himself in the younger version of himself
screaming like in a much scarier kind of way
I am the flash like in a very final kind of way
like he's fighting the older main version of Barry
the flag during the movie part of the idea I
think is that this younger version of Barry
starts traveling and trying to change things
over time he gets twisted into the dark evil
version of The Flash and he winds up encountering
that dark version of The Flash from different
points in the timeline throughout the movie
if you didn't watch The Flash TV show that's
basically like a savitar Twist he's basically
fighting a savitar version of himself because
savitar in The Flash TV show was just an older
version of Barry from later in the timeline who
had grown evil if he's spotted any other Easter
eggs or references during the trailer footage
that I didn't talk about during the video just
write down below in the comments and I'll do
more videos as we get more footage the next
couple of weeks we still have a couple more
weeks to go before it comes out in theaters
Spider-Man across the spider-verse just came
out in theaters it was great there were so many
Easter eggs and references I just did like an
hour long breakdown you can click here to watch
that there's so much stuff in that movie Henry
Cavill also saw The Flash movie recently and was
reacting to it you can click here to learn all
about that thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!